from this moment  every barbadian becomes the living  embodiment of the new republic  whether fair or foul wins come our way  vessel republic barbados has set sail on  her maiden voyage  [Music]  from the darkest days  of our past  and the appalling atrocity of slavery  which forever stains our history  the people of this island  forged their path with extraordinary  fortitude  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  may you continue to shine like a diamond  and bring honor to your nation by wherev  by your words by your actions  and to do credit wherever you shall go  be faithful and be true allegiance to  barbados according to law  so help me god  are barbarians  we the people must give republic  barbados its spirit and its substance  we must shape its future  we are each others and our nation's  keepers  we the people are barbados  [Applause]  so  [Music]  [Music]  you